gotcha is a georgian war veteran in
eastern ukraine
the conflict here is something he
recognizes
because russia has also supported
separatists in two breakaway regions
of georgia in 2008
the russian army invaded to support
their independence bid
the sound of shells exploding
reverberates across the fields
gotcha says russian-backed separatists
fire at ukrainian army positions
near here almost every day
did you hear that he says they're firing
120 millimeter caliber weapons
he takes us to the front line village of
shirokina
every building was either damaged or
completely destroyed
during fighting in 2015.
russia did many bad things to us in
georgia they occupied our territory as
they have done here in ukraine
i'm not against the russian nation or
people but their politics is a very
dirty game
georgian volunteers like gotcha started
coming to ukraine to fight
russian-backed separatists
at the start of the conflict in 2014
two years later the self-styled georgian
national legion
was incorporated into the ukrainian army
analysts say russia has encouraged and
supported territorial disputes
in ukraine as it did in georgia to
hinder the two countries
from joining nato
we georgians know what it means when
your dignity and liberty is taken
the ukrainians helped us and now it's
our turn to help them
they told us during our war that if we
didn't stop russia and georgia
then we would eventually have to stop
them in ukraine they predicted this
would happen
and they were the right
of gunshots can be heard every few
minutes
the morning started with shelling and
now snipers they are trying to provoke
us
to shoot back and find out our positions
this ukrainian soldier tells us there
are around 50 georgians that are working
with the ukrainian army right the way
along the front line the army here this
morning
very nervous they won't allow us to
progress any further up this road
because
in the last half an hour or so we've
heard what they describe as sniper fire
targeting a position very close to here
both sides accuse each other of
violating a 2015 ceasefire agreement
almost every day gotcha cleans his
weapon before going back to his
checkpoint
he says defending ukraine is his duty
and he won't be returning to georgia
anytime soon charles al jazeera
shirokina eastern ukraine